we are taking calls at 617-830-4750
let's go next to ronald reagan who is on
the line today
ronald what's going on hello
hey david how's it going good how are
you
good i wanted to say um i really
appreciated your tone
uh the tone of your show i think that
you
um are taking the threat of
of what's uh what we're staring down uh
very seriously and which threat is that
appreciate that
well what's coming uh in november
and what could come in another four
years
if we don't uh do the right thing got it
um yeah i mean i think there's a lot of
naval gazing on the left and sort of
like
you know like there's a time and a place
i feel like for
not that i'm some dnc lackey or anything
like that
but um it's just really frustrating i
think to
to see people um treating this as sort
of like
um situation normal and it's not um
i i do want to suggest um i don't know
if
if it's possible to line up a week of
shows or something like that where
you break down sort of like the
battleground states and there
electoral systems and who's in charge
and
what those states what the voting should
look like because
i do think on election night and
that time period afterwards like we're
likely to see some irregularities and
and
and it would be good if people are
prepared for that
i think that that is good you know i i
think to be totally transparent i think
a week of shows
listing state voting systems would be
pretty bad
i don't i don't think my audience would
appreciate that two weeks would be even
worse that would be twice as bad
but what i will continue to do is to let
people know
where it is that they can find out in
their state where can you early vote
when can you start early voting what's
the process for voting absentee can you
drop off your absentee ballot that i
will keep giving people the resources to
figure that out but i'm not going to do
two weeks of shows on that unfortunately
well all right yeah we've come to a
compromise
yeah i'm glad that we've done that yeah
uh keep keep up the good work
and uh one of my good friends who i mean
look
you don't have to put this on your show
if you don't want to but uh who i met
literally through the majority report
he's now
he's now a david pakman member and like
a big fan of your show
that doesn't mean so that's huge so um
you know i don't want you to think it's
all um
antagonistic coming from the ray gun i
love it
i love it all right my friend thank you
for the call
david all right we'll see it there's
ronald reagan not reagan like the
president
ray gun like a ray like a cathode ray
gun
as if if you can imagine that